on voit que depuis cette crise de plus
en plus d'agriculteurs souhaite passer
en bio parce qu'on voit bien que pour le
coup là le bio fonctionne et ça se vend
correctement à des prix qui sont à la
hauteur de l'investissement de
l'agriculteur finalement il faut quoi
monter en qualité pour pouvoir prétendre
à vivre correctement sans est mauvais
moi je crois que d'abord ce sont les
consommateurs qui choisissent ça qui est
intéressant c'est que on parlait tout à
l'heure des consom'acteurs cee
aujourd'hui qui oriente ils veulent les
petites fermes petite ou moyenne
ils veulent une agriculture de plus en
plus saines avec le bien-être animal
et ils veulent des produits d'agrium
eric sans pesticides 10 % du lait
aujourd'hui vendus en france du lait en
bouteille c'est du lait issu l'arrêter
au biologique c'est quand même un signe
très important
donc c'est pour ça qu'on se bat ici au
niveau du parlement pour essayer de
d'améliorer les règles sur l'agriculture
biologique pour faire en sorte qu'on
puisse augmenter le nombre alors
justement à ce propos josé bové la
transition est parfaite j'ai ouï dire qu
il y a un rapport avec ce faire il ya
une négociation en ce moment sur la
labellisation bio et que le rapporteur
qui est membre du groupe des verts dans
lequel vous êtes vous-même serait prêt à
lâcher face à la commission et au
conseil pour que l'on puisse avoir même
des pesticides dans les produits qui
seraient labellisés bio c'est vrai ou
pas est-ce que les verts van tu es le
bio alors ce qui était intéressant céder
effectivement c'est un vert allemand
martin gosling qui est rapporteur et
donc il est aujourd'hui dans ce qu'on
appelle le trilogue au niveau européen
c'est la négociait sa négociation avec
la commission de monsieur hogan s'est
pas celles de dacia ciolos qu'on avait
avant hétéro et le conseil sous
présidence néerlandaise et là c'est la
castagne c'est la castagne parce
qu'effectivement tout les libéraux
aujourd'hui refusent par exemple qu'on
puisse être dans une logique qui irait
on commence avec sa ferme sur une
production
et bien cette production demain
l'ensemble de l'exploitation devrait
être en bio à l'espace de sept ans dix
ans pour aller dans une dynamique
augmentation impossible de faire passer
ça pour l'instant impossible aussi
aujourd'hui c'est en train de nous dire
ben écoutez il ya peut-être des résidus
de pesticides mais c'est pas grave
finalement
en gros s'il ya des résidus de
pesticides ça va être déclassé mais qui
va payer
et c'est là où il faut avec le principe
pollueur payeur cdh les fabricants de
pesticides doivent payer parce que la
question biologique lui quand il flotte
tout son processus est contrôlé il a un
cahier des charges mais au final son
produit est pénalisé oui eh bien
personne lundi midi c'est un scandale
marc tarabella c'est un scandale mais il
faut l'enjeu il est clair c'est dommage
que josé bové n'a pas été rapporteur il
aurait été plus strict que son collègue
allemand il peut pas le dire lui moi je
le dis son collègue allemand est moins
efficace que lui mais lui peut pas le
dire ouvertement
je dis simplement qu'il faut préserver
le bio c'était une niche à une époque
aujourd'hui ça devient un business
ces 22 milliards d'euros à l'échelle
européenne est ce qu'il faut éviter
c'est de le dénaturer
pour faire entrer des gens qui ne
veulent pas faire du vrai bio et qui
trompent les consommateurs
et ça c'est de là qu'est l'enjeu
aujourd'hui la décertification c'est
important et effectivement il ya aussi
le code civil le même en france qu'en
belgique la responsabilité civile celui
qui pollue le champ son voisin doit
payer